hey everyone on YouTube it's John
Flixter here I'm going to talk about the
movie Logan lucky today
now it's actually Greg Alva here yeah
happy Memorial Day to everyone out there
filming this on Memorial Day and what
better movie trailer to do than Logan
lucky which takes place on Memorial Day
if I'm not mistaken Steven Soderbergh
coming out of retirement since 2013 was
his last movie he did before I go into
this trailer reaction review thing I
wanted to give a shout out to all drin D
he is the first person to buy t-shirts
from the real rejects and he says sober
photos of him wearing them there they
are him with the nipple chills that's my
quote that's when you know what trailer
is good when the NIP chills are there
and john and i as the two male
characters and the Devil's Rejects
posters my sister drew that one for you
for us you can follow my sister ex
married like X on Instagram check out
all our awesome art designs but aldrin D
thank you so much my friend you look
like a handsome Asia Matt you look
Filipino its cuddly this one you can
keep me warm during the winter my friend
winter is coming
[Music]
because three
I yeah we make just gonna say it I gotta
let you go you for just 5 pounds let go
for liability reasons involve an insurer
the one arms pop and dogmatic another so
a little escape
ouch shell Motor Speedway know anything
about below would have real thankful
through the joke bang and income and we
don't plan the kitchen
oh that's a couple of six hundreds of
the biggest race of the year
we need computer with I know everything
there is to know about the beauty okay
all the Twitter's I know welcome to the
coca-cola 600 what can I always ball
twenty yards oh pretty thirty it is
twenty or is it three we are um science
beer oh they're gonna know what we want
to know by lots of crown is only
[Music]
massively stupid a separate Marlon
[Music]
once your soldier naked notation because
that point so well must be simple
matters people say and you say that are
you getting my arm this one all right
welcome back steven soderbergh sewed
roberto juice but he's done so many
films Steven Soderbergh and you know
when he said he's taking that like
self-imposed retirement he was taking
who really believed he would not make a
film ever again and it happened sooner
that I thought I thought it would
probably like a decade before he made
like in the face like oh he's done work
on television in the past three years
but him returning the film is an
exciting time and for him to do so many
films was smart the trailers started off
with like the most fun movies he's
arguably made the oceans trilogy and
Magic Mike which is cool who's returning
with star Channing Tatum who he also
worked with in side effects little fun
fact trivia for you guys so promoting
the trailer start off with the oceans
movies is smart because this goes back
that's even so deburr type of flair that
type of style these guys are pulling off
a heist gets a lot of a signature type
of framing and colors that you'd want
from a Steven Soderbergh film this looks
like it's going to have that taste that
awesome dancer that you really knows how
to include in its films some really good
characters here I'm excited to see Adam
driver continuously branching out and
doing all different kinds of characters
because like a lot of people I was
introduced to Adam driver from the
showgirls I really enjoyed his
performance in silence I think isn't
okay kylo Ren I think he'll probably do
a better job in the last yet I thought I
hear you doing another kind of weird
character I use not your typical looking
Hollywood actor and I like seeing him do
weird roles here him and Channing Tatum
do look like they could be actual
brothers and a lot of ways I couldn't
help but think of a more fun version of
I water you know two brothers pulling
off a heist the southern accent the
character I'm most excited to see is
Daniel Craig because you know that's
actor who just seems he we all know him
made primarily for his road work his
bond with the dudes a legit actor he's a
damn good actor the first movie I ever
saw him in was road to perdition and
it's very apparent the guy wants to
break away from doing Bond in general
and I think he doesn't want to be
pigeonholed into doing action hero type
of characters and this movie after
coming off the sector is a good
transitional type of role I feel for him
because if film itself has an action
vibe about it it doesn't look like it's
necessarily action-packed but it's a
heist movie and there's some sub
sequences and dude is going to be some
action sequences in here so there's an
action flare about its tone that I'm
really enjoying
so having Daniel Craig in here just
makes sense but on top of that he's
doing a full-fledged character that
accident he's doing the look he has the
body language the mannerisms I'm excited
to see him be a full-on character
outside of what we've seen him do with
other big films like the Bond films or
girl with a dragon tattoo because if you
see films like layer-cake
Road to Perdition or even something like
defiance I think the guy is an amazing
talented actor you know I know they're
still kind of getting to meet bond but
it seems like he's pretty dead set on it
because I want him to still have a
flourishing career after officially
hanging up the bond Jersey and it's
rolled like this or he looks like he's
going to be the one who steals the show
Seth MacFarlane's and movie like this
that's one thing I like about Steven
Soderbergh too every once in a while he
does a casting choice that you wouldn't
necessarily expect he had Sasha Gray
star in a film he got Gina Carano Corino
I think that's her name you know I'm
talking about that MMA fighter put her
as a lead in haywire another movie that
she Channing Tatum has worked with so
Steven Soderbergh an awful what actually
Channing too was in haywire as well and
we didn't really see much of the other
cast I think Steven Soderbergh is great
with ensemble pieces because he loves
character he look he knows how to direct
his actors very well and you know
captain Watterson I'm not too familiar
with her works are inhaling covenant but
she's a really good job Katie Holmes to
me I sometimes feel like Katie Holmes
can do a really good job in movies I
mean she was never really regarded as
greatest actress ever but ever since
that marriage would Tom Cruise that she
had for a few years that really seemed
to be the thing that was taking her
career for a while so I'm hoping she
gets to do some cool stuff here and Seth
MacFarlane this movie is definitely a
Steven Soderbergh type of comedy the way
how the oceans trilogy was when Magic
Mike was so Seth MacFarlane being a
comedic actor but under the direction of
Steven Soderbergh I'm actually quite
intrigued to see what Seth MacFarlane
does with his role here because I'm not
I'm not too sure what live-action
material Seth MacFarlane has done
especially under the direction of
another director and we start in a
million with Dinah West he directed that
I felt that if someone else directed a
million wasted by the West he might have
done a better job in the performance
area someone to guide him and I feel
like Steven Soderbergh can bring out
great performances like Gina Carano I
really hope insane her name right it was
a pretty good job for someone has no
acting experience is a pretty damn good
job in that haywire movie I heard Sasha
Gray was surprisingly good in the
girlfriend experience
I didn't personally see it but a lot of
people I know that thoughts that she
doesn't actually a really good job for
coming off of being a porn actress
it's almost fresh it looks exciting it
looks really funny you know in Ocean's
eleven you got this big cast together
but most of them just show up to just
have a good time on set they're all just
being themselves on set me on George
Clooney George Clooney Brad Pitt Brad
Pitt you know the whole cast very few of
the actual members of Ocean's eleven get
to be full-on characters people like Don
Cheadle and that some got to be a
full-on character and hear all the
actors seem like they get it be full-on
characters they're not just showing up
to be their personalities they're
showing up to play an entire roll with
mannerisms changing their voice I'm
really looking forward to a Channing
Tatum I love that actor almost anything
if he's starring in it I'm immediately
drawn to wanting to see it and him in
soda brick I've done some pretty solid
films together and of course you know
Steven Soderbergh coming out of
retirement to direct a feature film I'm
really curious to see what was it about
this specific project that made him go
alright I got to come out and I'm going
to direct this one doesn't look like the
tone of solid a Soderbergh film of like
you know traffic or side effects this
more like the oceans trilogy and Magic
Mike the kubera side of Steven
Soderbergh so I'm pretty excited to see
this I'm pretty it up for you clutter so
dark because it just looks cool looks
like a cool fill alright guys well
thanks for tuning in you can subscribe
to the real rejects click that
notification bell to get notified
whenever one of our videos is out I'm at
the greg alba on instagram and twitter
go check out our patreon where we have a
lot of exclusive purse and video content
over there have a lot of love and
support happening from the community
thank you to all happy Memorial Day